[Music]
yeah what's up everyone welcome to
simulation today we are featuring the
general partner yeah what's up man
listen you know thank you for having me
I appreciate it yeah let's go up on
blockchain cryptocurrencies this new era
yeah yeah crazy times
crazy ties and it's so interesting how
its open Valley it's like the thing but
that if you go to like Sioux Falls I've
heard a lot from should be better now
yeah okay cool
it really just it's gonna flip a
hopefully not too much should be fun
alright so isn't that interesting though
how we go from people knowing about this
technology and like being so immersed in
it to people that don't know about it
and then there's Pete places in the
world that are still on their survival
it's just that this whole technology
thing is just I could talk about for so
long so let's go ahead no he's gonna say
I mean like everything there's always
bubbles everywhere right so here in San
Francisco well obviously it's everywhere
it's like everyone's living and breathe
it to a certain extent though it depends
on the inner soccer circles you're in
also like you know South Korea Singapore
some of these other markets were Russia
I need a tremendous amount and also it
comes from an adoption standpoint to
where you have I think that certain like
Russian airlines actually adopting the
the acceptance of cryptocurrency and
stuff like that so it's really siloed
but not just by country by like
different segments of the country as you
as you mentioned SF and you know with we
could talk about later s VBS I mean
there's different chapters being open
into so it's so crazy
yeah you just pulled up a good point
which is even across other nation
it's siloed into those bubbles in like
Moscow versus Siberia yeah okay
all right so for those that don't know
Joe is the co-founder of Daffy
Foundation which is a blockchain based
transportation company which is also
co-founder of a founding member of
Silver Valley blockchain Society
co-founder of matrix mining so
haven't good amount of talk about ugly
looking looking forward to this be good
so how did you initially even come up
with this realization that you were like
okay I gotta get in the blockchain
cryptocurrency say that two and a half
three years ago I attended a TEDx in San
Francisco which was fantastic and there
was a talk on blockchain and
unfortunately at the time I didn't pay
much attention to it I was sort of
confused and I was like I just didn't
take the time to really grasp the
technology which I feel like a lot of
people do and then about a year later so
I've been in it for about a year and a
half two years now my buddy was like
dude you got to check out etherium you
know from an investment standpoint yeah
so I started to dabble a little bit in
investing nothing too crazy but just
getting my feet wet and that was you
know a little bit earlier before things
starts like slingshot or then it sort of
hit the mass media so that was sort of
my initial you know dovetail into
cryptocurrency and blockchain as a whole
and then from there one thing led to
another where the business I was
currently working on we pivoted that
with the partners I was with until sort
of like a mining operation which I had
never thought that would happen I was
still doing some investing and then
eventually through the trying to get
funding for the mining operation I want
to running across the CEO of death of
Nome copal and we sort of met on
actually LinkedIn and just he was a
really good genuine person we sort of
hit it off and one thing led to another
he was just getting started with Davin
and here we are today okay it was crazy
it was a two and a half years yeah well
I mean I've actually been in the
blockchain space now maybe for about a
year and a half I feel like there's like
a six-month learning curve so everybody
could boy like I have no idea what
what's going on with it
but then anybody who spends maybe six
months in it you're at least entrenched
enough to understand because it's such a
new industry as well yeah it's been out
around for years but we're still very
very early adopters at its core yeah it
seems to be the reoccurring theme with
people's that they get in and
there's this learning curve just with
almost everything but especially with
watching there's people that understand
the technical aspect of it super duper
well there's people that are talking
about the geopolitical side of things
yes as well there's it's very
interesting how and I guess that seems
to be the same thing with the way that
you might we'll get like neuroscience
like the way that you either map the
brain really really well the technical
aspects or what does a broad
applications is have for the real world
yeah it seems to be that same things
going on a bit and for me it's more of a
nap I understand technology I'm not a
technologist I would say you know I'm
not going to be a developer coding and
things like that but I understand the
applications and even is speaking with
people people are so excited it seems
like you know sort of the dot-com boom
all over again and potentially bigger
the way everyone's making out to seem so
it's gonna also a lot of awesome social
impact as well so there's a lot of
different things um that really dive
into alright let's do it so let's start
off with okay so as you initially get
involved in it you have people around
you that are talking about mining and
then you guys decide to start a mining
operation yourselves yeah my one partner
in the company essentially how did that
a data center and then we took that data
center and just retrofitted it for a
mining operation we got that mining
operation okay and so then how does one
go about that process the two biggest
barriers to entry are access to
electricity cheap electricity and access
to hardware so as long as you have those
two things locked down you're going to
be able to do it the biggest thing with
hardware is everyone's trying to do this
so the supply is very limited so it's
very difficult to actually find the OEMs
that can go ahead and sell you the
quantity you need to actually make a
business out of this I've like graphics
processor yeah that's exactly GPU you
see these motherboards but primarily
GPUs there are the things that don't you
know aren't plentiful in supply right
now and
then also cheap electricity yet cheap
electricity as well so that's why you
have a lot of these mining operations
and places like Iceland or even
Washington State and then also where
it's cold right because a big thing is
heat control being able to go ahead and
and control the heat and get the cold
area and when need to get that warm air
out a lot of different ways there and us
put the base in the southeast of the und
end the south east over there because
that's that happened to be where my my
one partner had it might have his
operation had his data center Salina hot
don't know any hot but we were able to
manage that yeah yeah so then how do you
decide once you get the computers
rolling and starting to mind try and
solve these math problems for the block
chains how do you pick which bra chains
you're trying to solve the math problem
or an ER in those coins we were picking
pretty much based off like profitability
so essentially we remaining and still
stay on mining theorem so that was and
we could pretty much mine other
spin-offs of aetherium as well but we
decided on a theorem and then we can
make adjustments based off of different
possibilities levels as volatility
volatility swings and things like that
and also based off increased you know
hash rate how difficult it is to
actually mined these things there's a
lot of different variables yeah it's
different from a GPU verse an ASIC when
it comes to actual mining of you know
Bitcoin as opposed to something like an
aetherium or another all coin like that
so as the hash number increases the did
more difficult bill of math yes so if
one GPU is going to allow be able to do
a certain amount of hashes right and
then over time the hash rate increases
could you have more miners coming onto
the system and that means we're doing
more difficult so essentially your
profits are declining over time unless
you're constantly adding upgrading or
you know adding new GPUs and things like
that okay so then you picked aetherium
because you thought that etherium was
the best return for your electricity
that you were
getting and you can see you could switch
at any time yes so you know you can
point at it really the hardware we're
focusing on a etherium but then you bro
switch it any any point in time and say
okay as long as this one is gonna work
with the GPUs we've purchased then I can
go ahead and switch off these different
altcoins as well and right now the idea
is trying to put in as much electrical
[Music]
electricity as possible for as much
return as possible seems to be the you
want to try and find a place that's
gonna have a low energy cost essentially
low energy cost max returns now why
can't to the the hash I can't kick nu as
you're making the call for the etherium
blockchain that you're trying to figure
out what the math is there can you also
apply that same process to like ripples
blockchain can can you do that across
branches can you try to solve this math
arms across that's a good question a
cross block jeans I've stopped my head
I'm not sure I know that other ones that
are running on the etherion blockchain
we already able to other certain ones on
there um across jeans I'm not sure like
I said I'm I'm not so much of a
technical guy you're more like the you
know BD marketer yeah yeah you're still
doing a good job at keeping up and it
requires that as well on the BD and
marketing side of things to still have
that foundational knowledge which you
have so maybe well maybe we'll dive into
technical stuff I'll level technical
stuff along the way
we're not rather different also at
different we haven't even done the Derby
a blockchain the crypto show yet with a
super technical person will have to do
that maybe you can hook it up yeah so
okay now now that mining operations been
going on for about a year it's been
going on for
yeah maybe about maybe 10 months to a
year now a year okay and then then you
that the partner that you started dive
foundation with you met him a LinkedIn
yep you linked up he thought it was a
good yeah yes so pretty much a lot of my
energy shifted from the mining operation
over to dad I met I met no I'm
essentially on LinkedIn no um no I met
him on LinkedIn and he was interested in
hearing my background because when back
when is also on like brand marketing
content marketing marketing so he's
picking my brain and then I just have
like a pay it forward mentality so I was
let me see if I could find you some
freelancers let me give you some
feedback on the white paper let me give
us some feedback on the website which
wasn't yet live at the time and then we
did like a video chat then he run a pic
in San Francisco for an event a few
weeks later I believe and we met and
sort of clicked and you know when you
could tell someone's a good person right
and then he told me he asked me to you
know come on board so that's sort of
going from there
okay so let's touch on the definition so
then when you came on board what was the
thing that drew you to the blockchain
base transportation so there is a really
interesting idea you know hearing gnomes
speak about it very passionately was
really interesting we would have got me
totally hooked was one of the big things
I do is in the Bay Area go out and build
relationships with soon-to-be invited
visors so we've brought on like former
CTO of General Motors executives from s
AP from
forward from UPS so I was going out yeah
I mean like a stellar team yeah so I was
going out and I was meeting those people
and these people who have been in the
industry for you know 10 20 30 years
were super excited about the idea you
know and the idea of see now sort of
like a decentralized model and in the
future being you know in the in the
future having it be more autonomous as
well people were extremely excited about
it so that got me really dived up about
it and being like wow this is something
really interesting so yeah so initially
was just the overall interaction and
then didn't into the white paper and
everything like that but then the more I
spoke to people that were industry
experts and I realized like wow this is
gonna be a tremendous impact okay so you
said the CTO of General Motors yes and
these other people these other minds
that are understanding what is going on
in transportation transportations crazy
actually it's 90 percent of all goods
are transited by sea to other places in
that world and then once it usually gets
to the ports then it goes on trucks yeah
to the different areas and just so
mind-blowing how we move goods across
the world so and then this also applies
to people how you move people across the
world and their than their taxis and
movers and lifts and so ok so now why
does like what is def foundations like
main like what do you yeah
so what we're focused on is building the
underlying sort of transportation
infrastructure a protocol that connects
vehicles robotics drones user service
providers today what that looks like is
a decentralized model so taking the
middleman taking these corporations out
of the picture and having it be more
peer-to-peer
and then in the future once the adoption
takes place more of an autonomous model
right so we're not quite there from from
an autonomy standpoint for ships and for
cars we are in little test areas but not
on a larger scale
mostly trucks right though right now
trucks yeah they're certainly you know
like freight trucks and stuff like that
but from a drone standpoint we're a lot
closer than most people think
interesting I mean even on the uber over
here today I heard that uber eats was
doing tests
I think in San Diego on drone delivery
further for their platform so from drone
standpoint and we have partners like you
know we have a bunch of different
partisans on the code and something
called the data lines which essentially
is like different brands that are
looking to further transportation buying
into our protocol so we have a brand in
Russia called copter Express where now
we're working on autonomously having
that you know drone come and pick up a
package along the way you can now go
ahead and in a service station a
charging pad can autonomously bid on
that drone and then it can you know go
ahead and pull off charge and then
complete the mission so right now
because of where we are from a society
standpoint where we're focusing on more
over the decentralized marketplace
because that's where we are but autonomy
especially from a drone standpoint is
right around the corner and they're
blowing the protocol to be able to have
that you know build the foundation now
but then once a bee is ready to go it's
gonna fit right into the model alright
let's let's unpack so we have first in
Freight weren't Freight right now
and so you are wanting to send me a
freight shipment of your new coconut
water yeah and I am we're normally
you're paying a trucking company to take
the goods to me and then you're usually
paying them then they're dropping off
with me there's the but there is that
whole contractual system the protocol
makes the third party disappear correct
and then how does the goods how would
the goods get to me then via Freight how
would the coconut water get to me where
would the world would the middleman
percentage be out of that equation and
then how would
you or I be able to keep that percentage
since so the world ways that were able
to do this is because of the etherium
smart contract
well you enter into the contract that
you want to have this certain package
delivered and once it's delivered
you know it's then verified on the
blockchain and it's it's handed over to
you essentially yeah but they say you're
paid the trucking service that gets paid
along the way of course well it's
correct right as opposed me Joe
I want to send you coconut water or
whatever maybe it doesn't go for me to
intermediary then to you you goes
directly for me to you and riding the
blockchain along the way so if that
intermediate intermediary or charging a
ten fifteen twenty five percent fee on
top of it yeah that's where it comes in
the same goes for right sharing right
you have right now charging I think it's
like let's say twenty or twenty five
percent
yeah um you know for more of their
drivers so freely but also just even the
short-term decentralize ride-sharing you
put more money in the drivers pocket and
also may get cheaper pride for the user
as well exactly so so what we're looking
to create and what we're creating is a
peer-to-peer system that just connects
those people together okay so now let's
say that yeah let's say that I'm the
freight now and let's say that you're
let's say that you're carrying me from
here to San Jose Airport right you're
the one that I bid on then at that point
is the building cool who would make the
app infrastructure could be incentivized
to make that app infrastructure if
there's no developers getting paid and
designers getting paid to make that if
I'm paying you directly through a smart
contractors stuff there can be we're
focused on building the we're not in
profit right so we're focused on
building the underlying infrastructure
we're infrastructure for a protocol play
and we want companies to come in and
build on top of us so one example right
now is something we've called we built
as an example something called the
missions app so that's where I can you
know order a drone have that drone come
to me pick up something and then it will
be able to then you know deliver to you
as mentioned before along the way be
able to stop at a charging station
things like that so there's there's of
course the new ways for companies
to monetize it's sort of like you know
the way the internet was built right the
Internet is built and then you have all
these other domains on top of it these
multi-billion dollar companies on top of
it that can then take advantage of the
underlying protocols that were built
from from a computer standpoint from a
genetic standpoint okay so there will be
a way for someone to monetize on top of
the protocol yes but then so ideally
then the 25% fee will just go down to
maybe 2% or something like that the
thing is well here's the thing though
we're it opens it up to a tremendous
amount of more players so when you only
have a few major players in the game
like a lyft and uber it's very difficult
but we're making the application
extremely easy for anybody to come on so
if I have 30 30 cars that are sitting
here I can go ahead and undercut
everybody and then drive the entire
market price down so it's all up here to
peer I mean the goal is essentially
right if I have a drone or years from
now I have a self-driving car that can
become a passive income source for me I
can hook it on to the network and then
all of a sudden my car can be out
delivering you know delivering people
and passengers or goods for the next 7
days what needs to be charged its
notified it finds a charging station
what needs like you know to get air in
the tire goes you get to air on the tire
and then I want to go to Tahoe
snowboarding for the weekend I say hey
be back at this time you know it comes
back but we're essentially allowing the
vehicles to turn into passive income
source it's none of any you can the
discussion of like you know vehicles
owning other vehicles and yeah so but
yeah that I think the biggest incentive
and prey seduction yeah brands can still
start but the barrier to entry is much
lower because it's not going to it's not
going to be owned by all of these
monster players anymore you have anybody
being able to come to the game and say
hey I'm gonna put my car in the system
or my vehicle on the system and in
getting to work
connected to the person that wants to
bid on the car yes so people so people
could even create applications that is
just you know sort of like a connection
a connection right so I can go in and
actually me when I'm looking for a car
enter that system and then it would go
ahead and connect me to those people and
then people can link into that as well
and that's a protocol reporting like the
the communication the transaction the
discovery of those vehicle is an
individual okay so you're building the
discovery and the communication and the
protocol making the smart contract yes
you people you're building all that out
so that way as soon as I get onto daya
foundation then I'm already already gain
access to all of the different things
that I can yes
play smart place my money into for a
smart contract to do the service that I
want that way I don't need to and in
that way how does your nonprofit then
stay alive so we're really we're
currently in the process of doing a
token sale so raising 38 million dollars
for the token sale okay um it's been
going on for a few months now we've
raised a little just right around 20
million dollars so far
great yeah that's been good it's been
it's been this is my first time going
through a token sale so it's been it's
been an awesome learning experience
that's been a lot of work but it's been
it's been a really eye-opening and
lightning and seeing it from this side
is really valuable I think to answer
your your question we've obviously done
a good job initially it's at 38 isn't
just like oh this is the number we want
to go for this is like what we think is
a good number and then over time you
know there's different ug partners we go
he's bringing to them into the play and
things like that
help support you know the overall runway
or whatever it may be to actually make
sure that we're in it for the long term
and because we're still building that
out we could obviously if we needed to
build off ancillary businesses from that
but this core foundation is is a
non-profit then the team is a lot of
Engineers not engineers yet we have
right around 20 people right now Wow
yeah we have we have a good sized team
and they
the protocol they're building the
underlying foundation and then alright
let's go into the drone example because
this was really interesting you brought
it up I wanted attention that as we go
okay so uber is testing now this drug
delivery in San Diego and it's it's
difficult because it requires a lot of
battery a lot of charge in order to
actually be able to propel not only the
drill itself but them the goods that
it's carrying toward e to a distant
location so along the way there are
charge pads and so as its flying along
its way it makes a negotiation based on
its location with the charge pad and
then ill transact with the pad itself on
charging for three minutes for 50% of
its battery and then that whoever owns
the charge pad will earn that and
whoever owns the whoever's trying to get
the object of the good to the final
location will have to pay for the charge
pad then that transaction that occurs is
facilitated by a foundation by your
annoy protocol but also is the
that the transit of this good to the
spinal location has now become
completely without the use of another
party besides the one that's transiting
the good and the contracts that stopping
by to use along the way then the then
the there's no there's no middleman
percentages it's a direct payment to the
charge pad and it's a direct bring the
good to the final location correct and
that's precense you're burning really
right now you know being able to better
order order a drill to take you know a
cup of coffee or pizza - my girlfriend
across the city right along the way it
has to stop stop maybe once or twice to
be charged but maybe sends out you know
a sense to the different charging
stations and then the charging stations
will go ahead and and be able to bid
autonomously if we're talking about the
autonomy model right and then based off
that that decides okay this is of the
closest path and this is sort of the
communication protocol playing in right
and then it would go to their landing
the charging station charge for as long
as it would and all of his all these
transactions are happening in the damn
token which we've created so this is a
fiat currency as I run a clear
blockchain so it's the DEF token which
essentially is a token that we've
created there oh okay so this is using
the DEF token correct which is
essentially like a transportation token
ah
okay so then Domino's is delivering the
pizza to the final location you've
placed the order to bring it to your
girlfriend then you pay Domino's for the
pizza and then Domino's will use to dive
Foundations token network the
with the money value paid not
necessarily so so more so like total so
even right now we have like let's say
16,000 community members right we
brought to a community of 16,000 people
and rapidly growing so they're able to
you know a good amount of them are gonna
want to you know contribute to our token
sale and then receive damn turkeys for
that contribution and then they can take
that those tokens and utilize those
tokens for things like delivering of
goods or charging of drones or you know
system systems that pop up from a
decentralized vehicle standpoint so it's
more so the actual end user who's
actually utilizing the system being able
to take that token and then purchase
those goods or services with it okay and
then Daniels will have purchased our
like a hundred thousand after confirm
you and then now they have a collection
of these tokens that then they use maybe
six of your tokens to deliver the pizza
from where you purchased it to your
girlfriend sure if Domino's not to
direct if now if Domino's wants to use
the dead of protocol to you know let's
say they'd say okay listen this is
fantastic we want to do all of our
deliveries using death then they're
essentially doing that using our token
they're paying for everything using our
token yep okay and then the hardware of
the drone itself is owned by someone
else and manufacturer someone else
yeah we're not and we have we have in
our building partnerships with these
manufacturers whether they be drone
companies that we form the dive alliance
because what the dive alliance is its
yes its folks who are looking at the
forward forward-looking you know future
of Transportation and transportation as
it is today but it's also people who are
building these vehicles right whether
they be drones or Rovers or cars or
trucks and that's also why we want to
bring on your stellar advisors from your
like so you know your GM's and your
Fords and we're in conversation with
other auto manufacturers as well to
actually deliver or build those vehicles
which we could then integrate a protocol
until
okay so then let's continue on the pizza
example then repeats on your mind a good
example
okay okay you're delivering whatever
Italian food Chinese food what I was
being delivered to this girlfriend to
your final location to Joe's girlfriend
who are just kidding so or multiple
girlfriends what boyfriends were very
open so okay so now we're delivering the
goods to the final location okay now
there's there is an intermediary the
intermediary is the transportation but
they're not they're contracted by either
they have your the drone or the
autonomous vehicle or whatever
transporting the piece of the final
location has your protocol either built
into it or they're using your protocol
to take an agreement from down the nose
and then that's one smart contract is to
take the fish and Domino's and then they
get then that autonomous drone or
vehicle will then take the pizza and
then it'll go to or go as far as it can
and tell if it needs a charge or not or
I can go all the way and so either
negotiate with a charging location or
not but then this is all using this all
is using the DAF token the per protocol
okay so this so then again Domino's
would have your tokens they paid the
hardware company of the drone or the
autonomous vehicle an amount of your
tokens that they then could exchange for
this is so interesting because where do
you do with that tokens obviously you
can then go and use DAF tokens for other
DAF anything transportation where you
think about you know the older days when
you have like so their token to write a
a trolley whether in San Francisco we're
creating a transportation token whether
you are writing in the car or on a bus
or on a train or in arrow wherever maybe
it via drone now that we're looking
towards the future as well but the only
difference between using the fiat
currency versus using a DAF token is
that it gets put on the ledger
yes its blockchain technology it's
embossing technology the real it's
because it's the central like the the
ability for to not be centralized and
have this large decentralized ecosystem
which is trust us that's where the value
in the blockchain comes a large
researchers ecosystem that's trust less
so therefore we their kid there's not a
millionaire let's try to Jack their
prices up all of a sudden yeah maybe the
autonomous or transit company if this
wasn't blockchain related so it was just
us now related could at any point just
throw their pricing up sure I mean
there's companies right now that are
right working on autonomous technologies
and that they can essentially then hook
their vehicle into and into the system
as well
I feel like you know like you're getting
into this really you're getting your
your full arms and legs are like soaking
in the blockchain water right now and
and I'm like I have like a little
fingernail and they're trying to throw
us out it's fun yeah I got totally
entrenched in it you know it's it's
great but yeah not but not on not on
purpose initially and then it's sort of
yes but that's sort of what happens too
and it doesn't help living in San
Francisco where yeah well you live and
breathe it for sure
it's so interesting that how this
relates to the current way that we're
that were transiting goods across from
some a to be and how blockchain impacts
the way that we transit goods from point
A to point B I want to learn a clearer
picture of this okay let's try to make a
clearer picture of this when I use US
dollars to send a pizza from dominos to
girlfriend Domino's will either drive it
themselves
or they'll you put the pizza on someone
else's back that's already going there
or a drone or whatever and they could
pay them US dollar then there's no
digital ledger there may be visa would
take a fee or something if there
yeah sure Digital traitor okay so that
could be where the money gets saved is
through a transaction fee between the
two people that I found something good
and the manufacturer of the good yeah
okay look at multiple points yeah yeah
multiple points of transaction fees if
it has to stop and charge then it could
get a visa fee or ever and they also
realize outside of the outside of just
the fee also you know the benefit of the
bakken is I you know the security
security in fact that you know it's that
transaction that action is gonna always
be there it's verifiable everyone can
see it's open to the public so you know
a lot of things that we do also being
able to type back to you know ensure is
right so if there's certain vehicles are
driving around and then and something
happens unfortunately the insurer can
then see exactly what happened along the
way you have lists of different
transactions and they have the history
of these things is there any foul play
so there's a lot of different there's a
lot of players in the game even more so
that you know it's very difficult to
wrap your head it on everything but
they're just so many players in the game
constantly where the blockchain makes
everything a lot easier over time you
know from a transparency standpoint and
these schemas laughing kidding about
transparency we are like or overly
transparent about everything at dev we
sort of have this this model where we
even do this thing where you think of a
daily dive where it's a daily
transparency the issue is because I
think a lot of people initially
especially outside of like the areas
that were in even you go to anywhere
elected what in the US a Bitcoin other
to scam you know or something of that
sort so a lot of there's always
unfortunately lot of bad eggs not a lot
but a few enough to get a bad rap for
anything so we try and deploy the truly
transparent about everything so he posts
daily videos each individual on the team
but we were working on a video yeah yeah
adapt our network yeah say yes
essentially you know if you would go to
dab actually at the bottom of a website
it always repopulate the newest daily
dev and then we also do you know so many
YouTube video as well it's just a quick
and here's my main focus yesterday
here's my main focus today which I
enjoyed isn't very actually driven and
disciplined and stuff like that so it
helps people see what you're working on
and the real community members retreat
both have an awesome following can see
and get to know each personality as well
which is fun okay I want to ask this
question it's about the
it's about the ledger itself and how
much electricity this uses it for the
mining operation so do we need to know
that you sent your girlfriend a pizza at
six o'clock on Monday do we really need
to know that does it need to be
digitally stored forever that's
specifically it's a question that
specifically no but I think that there
are transactions that you could then
verify against whether or not these are
good actors or bad actors and things
like that over the course of time that
really play in especially when it comes
to I want to know if I'm getting a ride
from somebody if they've been in four
accidents before right I like things
like that that will make a difference
and will be will have an impact on how
you perceive things and what you want to
be doing there's nothing for yet those
little more fun use case sure that the
impact there is is better than that
okay hey I agree that so that's an
important one you want to know the
digital ledger of failure safety of four
good actors versus bad actors you want
to be able to distinguish between the
two it's just even for asthma as
mentioned before like insures and
suppliers and things like that it allows
transparency into things which which
wasn't otherwise accepts a little
beforehand and also you know it's not
all being stored if we're talking about
the blockchain it's all not being stored
on one location it's not at within one
Bank or the information isn't right
there where unfortunately someone can
press a button or someone could have a
bad day and do something that would
affect millions of people I mean we see
reaches happening as well when it comes
to security I'm in San Francisco we have
another co-founder John who's in uh
who's in Vancouver we have our head
counsel who actually can deliver from
the aphelion foundation she was a sec
commissioner she's in Y which she's
she's that role yeah well she's um she's
fantastic
she was a eight year commissioner for
the sec of Hawaii and then was General
Counsel for aetherium and then we were
lucky enough to have her joined a few
months ago and he doesn't work here I
talked to her like almost daily because
all the legal stipulation there's a lot
of you know it's craziness right now
especially in the US and that's actually
why we decided from a contribution
standpoint not to allow any any us any
China investment actually no u.s. or
China an investment yeah and because of
the SEC because it was your thought
uncertainty so we made the decision that
would be better just to not not raise
any you know funds here
so then even if somebody does want to
raise funds that Wolf's here they can
always use their account some no you
can't you can't you can't you can't be
like if you can't be a citizen you can't
be you can't be a citizen you can't have
a passport here you can't reside here
you can't even even if I were even if I
were let's say a citizen of Australia
and I was traveling here
you still can't you know make the
contribution while you're on US soil and
the reason is because if they invest
five million into the Deaf foundation
then the SEC cuz then they get tokens so
yeah it's just there's a lot of
uncertainty right now around the whole
token landscape which which really
because it moves at the speed of light I
mean at a day or a week when it comes to
you know sort of everything happening on
the block cannon cryptocurrency it's
like a month in technology they just
underlie but it happens extremely
quickly but so does you know and then
the regulators are expected to keep up
with this
so from another standpoint it was just a
safest move to not you know not
associate ourselves with taking any no
contribution from from the u.s. or China
because of the uncertainty currently
and see that is soon yeah yeah you know
we'll see what happens yeah hopefully we
figured out so funny seeing technology
run like a racehorse and see the
government like a turtle behind it and
try to figure out how to regulate yeah
just yeah just what do you think the
private sector is really pushing things
forward Frank Zappa said the pollen
politics are the entertainment division
of the military-industrial complex so
it's it's easy to see the private sector
doesn't move things forward super fast
so the government tries to regulate
behind it usually George weather is that
well yeah yeah he said the government
gets in the way here up here on this it
does I believe that I worked with two
municipalities one in my hometown and
one in Franklin New Hampshire it was a
collective conscious they were all the
same personality just different places
it was frightening but that was the last
time I worked for and supported any
government
they were tough I mean yeah it's it's a
tough especially as we continue to
advance and science and technology
continues to get found on each other you
know regards so way we're gonna be and
what we're going to go it's it's it's a
big undertaking and also the idea of
regulation isn't all bad and we talked
to this with George Cayley we've talked
to this with a lot of people that have
been on our show before but that's that
that is the challenge of Science and
Technology that like a racehorse forward
the turtle has to figure out how to
figure how to regulate along the way
that doesn't impede the racehorse from
running forward but that also keeps the
population safe yeah safe safety safety
there's no money in safety so okay how
about we all right let's flip our sure
let's do it all right here we go
flip my timer yeah fifteen minute well
can you give us the noise - sure yeah
let's do it
[Music]
fifteen minutes okay
so fix your mind yeah I know so it's
difficult to set up a lavalier mic on a
t-shirt I'll have to figure out how to
do this better
yeah well I only work with to the
Nationals so yeah edit this you go
straight through just go straight
through sure makes me celebrate
mediocrity
yeah the content is good but you know
the execution of it it's we're amateurs
we're working on it
well what kind of thanks to you guys for
keeping us keeping us in check along the
way all right all right moving on okay
what is the most
impactful application that this is gonna
have in the next couple of years I'm
talking about a lot of them that you're
working on
okay pick an image it just it's such a
big there's so many different
applications right we're working on
transparency from energy to housing to
funding I recently met with and I've
been seeing around town a lot the vice
mayor of Berkeley been they let great
guy he's working on a micro bond
initiative over there to essentially
have the individuals of the town to be
able to fund you know fire truck
initially based you know all based on
the blockchain things like that so the
applications are far and wide I think if
you even look at some you know some
necessary volve lesser far along
countries you know you're able to have
titles right where people wouldn't
otherwise be able to say this is my
property there's another title system in
place and now you'll be able to go ahead
and put that in place also there's also
big a bit of big trend from US citizens
going to Puerto Rico a new buddy of mine
he's studying some no comic podcast
called like crypto Rico or something
like that so yeah it's just there's a
there's a ton of different use cases
from the transportation standpoint I
think it's gonna have a tremendous
tremendous tremendous impact especially
with everything we're working on and as
I said you know a lot of specific social
impacts as well outside you know I said
what we're doing also all right how
about how do we figure out how the work
across the world across these borders in
our globalized world how do we figure
out how to work in that sense rule will
China's watchin and Russia's watching
would be accessible
yeah United States companies it's
interesting I think what blockchain and
cryptocurrency has done is actually
allowed us to
really feel what it may look like to be
borderless yeah it's so crazy you know
because now all of a sudden people that
were never interested in what was
happening in South Korea or Singapore or
Russia now have have to pay attention
because it's going to directly impact
maybe a certain investment or or say
that they have in the cryptocurrency
market so that's it's it's super
fascinating to see that happen and see
what happens if we're also you but like
you can sort of sort of combine forces
and work together around that that's
been that's been really interesting to
see like how you say that the
decentralization is actually I went to
the mic killing years decentralization
actually cause us to get more borderless
I like that I do struggle with seeing
how we'll if China is already throttling
connection to Facebook and Google then
how we that's already the Internet the
Internet's already a decentralized state
but somehow they figure out how to
centralize why are you always picking on
China well I really I don't I can't even
think of another country that throttles
connection to the Internet but I'm sure
there's plenty of other ones yeah there
was like the Egypt issue and then not
really
as in North Korea there that's an easy
one North Korea that if they don't know
how to do that with the internet holily
not that I mean they'll figure out how
to do with the blocking you just
centralized a blockchain not give access
to other people like trying to decided
to have their own communist party
blockchain then there will be no way for
another government to access it and
engage with it I don't know I think I
think it might feel a little different
this time there's a lot of a lot of
capital involved so I think that if
certain countries were to just know
outright block things people get
creative and find different ways
different ways yeah now let's let's hope
to find all the unique creative ways to
collectively move forward as one let's
see if we can do that yes that's so
that's a lot of what our show is about
it's try to figure out how to ask these
tough questions so that way we can
figure out how to move forward all right
how about we ask what do you think about
cryptocurrency exacerbating wealth
inequality
that's having a shift in essentially
like old wealth or was new awful well
even right now there's so many hidden
billionaires on these different
cryptocurrencies now that have despond
in the last couple of years boom these
new burners now meanwhile like you can
see that that overall wealth increase is
or magnitudes versus these bottom
dwellers on the socioeconomic status are
literally making another couple bucks an
hour yeah so what's uh what's going on
how do you think we're gonna end up
moving and solving this wealth
inequality there's actually some
interesting on
a friend of mine is the CEO of a corny
called you Baku coin you bit coke weird
yeah this you pick a coin and
essentially like what he's doing is he
wants to think of like us we're very
privileged right we have all of these
different asset vehicles and investment
vehicles what we could do you know
mutual funds and this and that and we
can do some sort of wealth that way a
lot of people in third-world countries
don't have access to that so what he's
developing is such a system that gives
access to those people to those
investment vehicles who wouldn't
otherwise have access to that so I think
sure you're always gonna have people
that raise to the top because they made
early investments and things like that
but as a whole and also come to the
title title thing now because I own land
and it's proven on the blockchain I
could maybe take out a loan and so a
small business based off that so I think
the blockchain outside of just like
thinking about it from I put an X and I
got why and I got early and I got lucky
or whatever maybe I think it will enable
hopefully more wealth to grow that way
that's a good perspective I like
electrolyte he's very optimistic about
what the technology yeah I do too I'm
also very realistic but I do also agree
that the optimism so crucial like you
said you gave a bunch of really good
examples about how people are leveraging
the technology to help people then in
the lower socioeconomic status is
gaining wealth all right how about a
couple quick rapid-fire questions do you
think they are alone in the cosmos no of
course not why it's just what's way to
it's way too vast there's way too many
just really too vast was waiting me out
unknowns out there their breasts and
there's a higher being behind what
happened here but there's just too much
out there for there not to be something
else there
what does that
you're being look like to you or feel
like to you I mean whether it's you know
gather energy or
I sort of have a mix of other mix of
feelings that whether it's you know
whether it's bad energy
some divinity helped empower the
evolution on earth yeah yeah no I think
I think this I think there's something
out there
you know where we run elaborate as if
there's a there's a higher force at work
in my opinion uh-huh yeah we talked a
lot about what exists outside of the 3d
reality no we don't we don't discuss
nothing we know nothing and we don't
talk about it do you think we're the
computer simulation no why I don't think
we're the computer simulation
specifically you know you've been
watching a lot of was it dark that near
buckner III just I have seen that but I
really like this question of the
computer simulation yeah you said no why
I mean it's a computer simulation you
think that were all just we're programs
being run on this earth well like in
something some sort of game not that
we're dreaming or like it is a lucid
dream or something like that it's more I
mean just elaborate a bit it could be
like a brain in the VAT it could be the
just that same higher force that you
were just talking about before but same
higher force is just a programmer of the
reality that you see I'm just tweaking
all the variables yeah proximity of the
star different mass of the planet
different evolutionary time light for
the species maybe a species that has
decided to drop nukes decided not to
drop nukes what does that look like
weather I don't think we're in a
computer simulation weather were
influenced as human beings by other more
advanced civilizations let's say that is
unsaid but I don't think per say that we
are in a computer simulation
okay and just to piggyback off that a
little bit more is what does it look
like to you
what does it feel like to have advanced
civilizations manipulating our world
where would you say that would be like
how many we be on how long have we been
on earth for like a couple million years
as humans as humans yeah a couple of
million years yeah you know it goes back
to you know things when the pyramids and
the different you know drones and things
like that
I I don't know I mean it's it's an
interesting question I don't know that I
have a specific answer for you I'm not
I'm okay with how things are now I think
that things can always improve I think
that there's a lot of good that needs to
be done the world still tremendous a
tremendous amount of good right well
hell yeah yeah I'm sure we're up to for
sure
so that without question that whether
somebody or something is out-and-out
external influence I would hope that
they're trying to influence in a
positive manner okay and last question
is what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
yes
tell us why
it's very pure motion so being able to
feel the emotion of love is something
that you can't describe with words or
visuals it has to be a feeling so that's
why emotions are extremely extremely
powerful yes I think love is probably
one of the most powerful emotions
Joey Potter thank you sir what a
pleasure plug it this is good super fun
I really appreciate it there's so much
to still unpack and understand about
blockchain and the potential of the
technology across transportation across
every other aspect of secure securing
moving goods and doing it in ways that
are effective efficient digitally secure
over time decreasing the amount of third
parties that take percentages along the
way we're moving into drones we got
autonomous vehicles already transiting
people transiting goods you know right
there you're right there building out
the protocol for the for the freight for
the for humans for drones this is really
important stuff yeah men and that's why
you have our 20 mil raised of your 30 to
38 at your alien race that's super
impressive camping you're not taking
funds from us or China that is crazy
stuff we got to figure out the sec
what's going on with that it's a lot to
figure out still we learned a lot about
about mining as well about about what
we're gonna do moving forward especially
about like all the electricity has to be
used to figure this out a lot all right
all right
Joe is such a pleasure thanks everyone
for tuning in if you guys had a good
time please share the content with other
people let's get this these
conversations rolling about crypto
blockchain about transiting goods and
what the underlying protocol is gonna be
let's share the concert with other
people like the content comment below
with your thoughts we'd love to hear
from you you have you get the
opportunity to be featured on our
Instagram now and our Twitter will
feature your comments so go and give us
a comment below also subscribe press
that subscribe button if you'd like to
gently if you'd like to smash totally up
to you you get to pick but you scribe
easy easy easy press also we're on
patreon you already know that so
important for us to continue sustaining
this so help us with the studio help us
expand help us get more creative
people involved in the process of
sharing this content across the world
let's let work our way up to a football
stadium work our way up to creative
warehouse Ronnie Vargas our producing
partner thank you so much and we'll see
you guys soon peace thank you
[Music]